ahora veremos la idea de utilidad en
economía en el lenguaje cotidiano cuando
alguien pregunta cuál es la utilidad de
eso normalmente se refieren a la
utilidad que tienen las cosas y la
utilidad en economía toma esa idea de
utilidad y la expande un poco más en
economía podemos pensar en la utilidad
como una forma de medir la satisfacción
la importancia o el valor de algo
incluso hay quienes dicen que mide la
felicidad que proporciona algo porque
algunos objetos que no tienen un valor
práctico pueden ser útiles en economía
porque proporcionan cierta satisfacción
o felicidad y como ven esto es algo que
los economistas tratan de medir o de
cuantificar y lo hacen con una unidad de
utilidad veamos un ejemplo de esto
imaginemos que queremos calcular la
utilidad que obtenemos a partir de bolas
de helado vamos a crear una tabla en la
columna izquierda está el número de
bolas de helado y en la columna derecha
está la utilidad total que mediremos en
utilidades que es la unidad de la
utilidad aquí está la tabla si tenemos
cero bolas de helado seguro adivinan
cuál será la utilidad de
es cero qué pasa si tenemos una bola de
helado digamos que tiene 80 unidades de
utilidad y seguro se preguntan de dónde
salió este 80 de utilidad este es un
número que elegí de forma arbitraria
pero lo más importante es cómo se
compara este 80 con las utilidades de
otras cosas por ejemplo usando esta
misma escala cómo se compara esto con
dos bolas de helado mi utilidad total es
140 y este 80 y el 140 no son lo
importante lo importante aquí son las
proporciones que hay entre estos dos si
digo que la utilidad de una bola de
helado es 800 entonces si esta
proporción se mantiene la utilidad de
dos bolas de helado va a ser de 1400 si
esto fuera 8 millones
esto sería 14 millones lo importante es
la utilidad relativa aquí simplemente de
un valor a la utilidad total de una bola
de helado continuemos
de esta proporción entonces digamos que
tres bolas de helado generan 180
unidades de utilidad total y quizás se
pregunten que aún cuando la proporción
sea correcta cómo podemos saber que esta
proporción es así los economistas pueden
debatir sobre cómo obtener estos valores
pero algunas formas de hacerlo es
preguntarse cuánto pagarían las personas
por estos objetos y después obtener las
proporciones o se puede encuestar a las
personas y preguntarles en una escala
del 1 al 10 que tanto le hace feliz el
tener una bola de helado luego 2 bolas
de helado luego 3 bolas de helado y
después calcular las proporciones entre
las respuestas sin duda esto no es una
ciencia exacta pero las personas tratan
de cuantificar esto continuemos con la
cuarta bola de helado digamos que
sabemos que la cuarta bola de helado
tiene una utilidad total de 170 aquí
ocurre algo interesante conforme aumenta
la cantidad de bolas de helado de 0 a 1
de 1 a 2 de 2 a 3 parece que obtenemos
una mayor utilidad pero de pronto cuando
tenemos cuatro bolas de helado
la utilidad disminuye un poco quizá esto
se deba a que las personas no terminan
de comer cuatro bolas de helado y no
saben qué hacer con la cuarta bola que
termina derritiéndose por lo que no se
obtiene tanta utilidad de esa cuarta
bola de helado ya que nos hace sentir
culpables de que se desperdicia a
diferencia de tener solamente tres bolas
de helado otra cosa para pensar es en
que tanto aumenta la utilidad total cada
vez que tenemos una bola adicional
hablaremos de esto con más detalle en
futuros vídeos pero la idea general es
que tanta utilidad más se obtiene por
cada unidad adicional en economía cuando
hablamos de qué pasa con el aumento
usamos la palabra marginal en este caso
es la utilidad marginal que a veces se
abrevia como un omg y cuyas unidades
siguen siendo en utilidades vamos a
calcularla cuando pasamos de no tener
bolas de helado a tener una bola de
helado cuál es la utilidad marginal pues
vemos un incremento de 80 unidades por
lo que la utilidad marginal es 80
y de la segunda bola de helado sabemos
que una bola de 80 unidades de utilidad
y ahora tenemos 2 la utilidad total es
de 140 por lo que con esa bola adicional
pasamos de 80 a 140 lo que nos da 60
unidades de utilidad extra noten que nos
dio mucha felicidad esa primera bola de
helado y que también nos dio felicidad
la segunda bola de helado pero no tanta
como la primera quizá porque ya no
tenemos tanto antojo o porque ya nos
cansó un poco el helado y esto sigue
pasando con la tercera bola de helado
cuando pasamos de 140 a 180 nos da 40
unidades de utilidad y como mencionamos
antes cuando pasamos de tres bolas a
cuatro bolas de helado no sólo no
aumenta la utilidad total sino que resta
unidades de utilidad tenemos un margen
de utilidad negativo de menos 10 esa
cuarta bola de helado nos quitó
felicidad vamos a dejar esto aquí
analizamos la idea de utilidad total y
la idea de utilidad marginal en este
ejemplo vimos un comportamiento típico
en el que la utilidad marginal disminuye
conforme tenemos más
desde este objeto en futuros vídeos
usaremos estos conceptos de utilidad
total y utilidad marginal para analizar
cómo es que las personas toman
decisiones para optimizar su utilidad
total nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo